hello everyone and welcome to today's
session we will be starting here
in a few more minutes which is around 15
minutes
and thank you so much dr anita for
joining us today
thank you sir everyone
[Music]
three
hi everyone thank you again for joining
so we will be starting here
in another 10 more minutes at 3 pm
gmt which is uh 9 a.m cst
so you are welcome to ask us any
questions
in the chat box our team is present here
and we will be answering your questions
and during the presentation we will
pause to ask you if you have any
questions so you can
at that point of time unmute yourself
and also so
directly interact with the speaker and
we are
also live right now in youtube
so if you would uh feel that you would
want to watch on youtube you can also
find us
on pine biotech is the name of the
channel and we are
live right now so thank you again for
joining we are starting
shortly
uh it's almost 3 pm gmt and we are ready
to start in another
few minutes so that everybody can join
today's session so
thank you for patiently waiting for
those of you who have joined us
earlier we will be beginning
soon
okay
uh
welcome to this free webinar on
bioinformatics for
infectious diseases in today's webinar
we will speak about bioinformatics for
infectious disease research and present
use cases for bioinformatics analysis
methods
that are used in viral evolutionary
studies
antiviral drug discovery as well as the
emergence
of drug resistance in bacterial
pathogens
we will also showcase some of the latest
developments
on the t-bio info platform designed for
virology studies and introduce the
upcoming omics logic training program
for those interested in effective
utilization of bioinformatics
for infectious diseases immunology
and microbiology
as part of our upcoming training program
for students and researchers
with a focus on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
today's webinar will introduce you to
the ways
host pathogen interaction can be studied
using
ngs data analysis
my name is beepsha biswas and
i am the omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are part of our bioinformatics community
managed by pine biotech
over the past couple of years we have
seen participants from all over the
world
join our training programs take online
coursework and utilize our big data
analysis
tools in various research projects
let me start by introducing our company
and collaborators to share with you
details
about the upcoming program
what we will discuss today and
throughout this program is a result of
hard work by an
amazing team led by company co-founders
dr
alfred tauber and dr leonid brodsky
dr tober comes from a medical background
and has extensive expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and has
been recognized internationally for his
generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives that support
training and applications in medicine
dr brodsky is the director of the tobor
bioinformatics research center at
university of haifa
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical
data uh pardon me uh dr anita
uh can you cannot see the screen uh
is the screen visible
no yeah it is it is visible to me
okay can everybody see it
right here for me as well
okay yes i can see it as well
thank you so much uh for letting me know
yes i can also see the screen
uh dr anita if you're having a problem
dr mood if you can just help
dr anita i'm sorry
okay thank you so much for letting me
know so i'll continue
uh with the presentation now
okay so as i mentioned
under dr brodsky's leadership the topper
research center started collaboration
in research teams at universities like
the university of california san
francisco
institute pasteur tulane university and
many others
where research labs are working on
cutting-edge research projects studying
viral and bacterial infections and
designing
novel drugs and vaccines to treat and
prevent
infectious diseases and the rest of the
team that you see here
there are a lot of team members who are
bioinformaticians computer scientists
and we will meet some of them today in
this session
the goal of the omics logic program is
to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent research
guided by mentors and peer example
developing a growing community with
shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation of
citizen science enabling students
clinicians and
to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology in life and data
sciences
and i would like to request everyone to
kindly mute yourself as a presentation
is going on so that
every participant can hear the speakers
and the speakers can also interact with
the participants
thank you so much
and before we move ahead i would like to
invite you to join our social media
groups
which are there in linkedin and facebook
and i will just
take you to our website so that
you can see these different pages and
groups that we have
and for francis who is asking if you can
record the session the session is
already live
in youtube and you will be able to
review the session
even later on so i'm posting
the links to the groups if you're
already a member of the group
uh thank you for joining and if you are
not yet a member
you are welcome to come and join these
groups
and secondly i would like to ask
all of you to come with me to edu.t
bioinfo so let me paste that link for
you
here in the chat box so once you are
here
please let me know if you already have
an account on edut bio info
we have a step-by-step guide on how to
make the most
out of your profile on edut bio info
and if you do not yet have an account i
would like to
invite everyone to go ahead and create a
free account on a
duty bio info and during the course
of today's session as well as the rest
of the upcoming program you will see
that
why we are asking you to create this
free account
because we will be sharing a lot of the
free resources
so while we are discussing you can go
ahead and create a free account on edu
dot t hyphen bio dot info so let me go
back
to the presentation
and i hope that you are able to utilize
the
profile resource to update your own
profile
and that is going to be really helpful
so now let me introduce you to the
program
mentors in the upcoming omics logic
program you will have the
opportunity to interact and collaborate
with an international team of
experts specialized in the application
of data science to biological data sets
let me introduce you to the main
speakers of today's session
dr anita gansha is the senior research
fellow at noguchi memorial institute for
medical research
at the university of hana her area of
work
is in genomics of infectious diseases
she applies data analytics to explore
pathogen genome data for signatures of
the emergence and spread
of drug resistant pathogens virulence
pathogens in response to
disease control interventions dr gansha
has
also been an active participant in our
recent omits logic programs
and is now a collaborator and mentor in
the upcoming
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
dr mohit mazumdar is our omics logic
project mentor and an
expert in big data computational
analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology
and over 10 years of experience working
with industry and academia
elia prodzky is fine biotech co-founder
and ceo in his current role he has
extensive experience
working together with industry and
academic partners that are applying
multi-omics integration and
bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications
like why bioinformatics is an essential
skill for those
involved in infectious disease research
as well as health policy
how biafra matrix is used in projects
and what are some of the examples
and what are the benefits of this study
for
students clinicians and researchers that
elia also will be covering
in today's session
dr harpreet kaur is our omits logic
trainer
she guides the participants
in the hands-on sessions and with
project and data analysis during the
program her area of specialization is in
genomics and machine learning
i will now like to invite dr anita
gansha
to talk about her interest in
bioinformatics and the way
omits logic training has helped her
leverage
data analysis in our current malaria
research
dr anita over to you
thank you bibsa let me share my screen
um
all right
um
there should be a oh okay can you see my
screen now
yeah do you have a slide
view itself right so um
good afternoon to you all
and thank you for joining us and good
morning
to those of us in the us thank you for
joining us for the first
in the series of um bioinformatics
training that
noguchi memorial institute for medical
research in collaboration with
pine biotech is organizing
for um infectious disease
research so this afternoon
i'm going to give you just a teaser i
know that it is um
after lunch people are tired and all
that so i've decided to give you a
cartoon version
of why bioinformatics for infectious
disease
public health and research my name as
was mentioned is anita ganza
and i work at the witch memorial
institute for medical research
so my goal is just to
show you how bioinformatics can be used
to
help us prevent um
as from dying of something that is very
awful maybe
covet yeah so that's basically what i'm
aiming to do this afternoon
so before i even start i want to ask
what is bioinformatics
is it for genomics analysis for
evolutionary studies is it for
biological algorithm development is it
for drug design
so basically you can see how we are all
scrambling to
find our niche on the bioinformatics um
platform
now why do we need bioinformatics as a
stance
most of us what we do is to collect a
lot of data
and then we scratch the surface do some
analysis and put the rest down and hope
that one day
we'll come back to it um i think
um this is why we need bioinformatics
for our research activities
so bioinformatics is that's discipline
the scientific discipline that manages
engineering computer science chemistry
biochemistry biology
statistics to make sense of data
ultimately for improving health
and so we see that the biologist is
interested in the sequences
whether it is genomics proteomics
transcriptomics
data and then the computer scientist
is in charge of the algorithms the
statistician does the statistical
analysis
and the chemists is also involved with
the protein structures and how
all these will come together for a good
bioinformatics
pipeline now in public health
we are interested in health protection
surveillance
prevention health assessment
health promotion and um
emergence preparedness so when there is
any outbreak we are interested in how we
can
fight this outbreak so
what are some of the questions that we
ask in public health
um we take some posts from patients for
diagnosis
we want to know what the patients has
and how the patients
can be treated we study some posts for
surveillance
so what is circulating in the population
and what does it mean
for public health and then we also take
environmental samples
to know what's circulating our water
bodies or
water that we drink food and what this
means to
public health now
in case there's an outbreak how do we
investigate this
outbreak so for instance we are all
aware of the size of
infection how do we investigate such an
outbreak these are some of the questions
that
are public health importance to us so
we conduct surveillances to identify
cases people who are infected and these
surveillances
can include molecular epidemiology
genotyping of the pathogens
so surveillance is identifying the
various cases
then we can also go further with the
molecular epidemiology
to identify potentially which pathogens
are related
so we see some relations between the
identified pathogens in the surveillance
then the field epidemiologist is
interested
in tracking the transmission how the
infection is
being transmitted but
that is not enough
[Music]
these genotyping methods that we've
i spoke about in the previous slide may
not necessarily tell you the order or
the direction of the
transmission and then the size of the
clusters that you attain
from the um genotyping
will depend on the type of method that
you use so the more detailed you go
the more information you get about the
pathogen you are interested in
now we need a lot of
epidemiological data to marry these two
and most of the time we do not have
sufficient
ep information to understand even the
genotypes that
we have attained now in summary these
are some of the
roadblocks that we encounter diagnostics
is very time consuming and um
we end up not taking a lot of samples in
the population to understand the actual
dynamics of the
infection now
coming up with the exact phenotype is
very very slow it takes
days especially for a diagnosis like um
tb and then
the surveillance that we currently do
are very low resolution
because we are using genotyping or
methods that are
um low resolution
and then relies a lot on epidemiological
data
so the whole process is very complex
there are so many parallel steps
and reporting at various stages and so
these roadblocks
we need to surmount now how do we summon
such a roadblock
this is where we need genomics genomics
promises to help us among some of these
roadblocks
yes i know it's still early days
some parts of the world have made a lot
of progress
we are trying in africa to also
apply genomics in our public health
systems
so we are all aware of how the
technology has advanced we have various
sequencing
platforms i don't even know the names of
these ones the my sig the high six
and the more um where we think the
future will be
the ion turin um
platforms we think that
at the moment we are thinking that we
can use
um whole genome sequencing to help with
rapid diagnosis we believe that the
genomes
of these pathogens contain almost
everything that we need for diagnosis
for phenotyping and for surveillance so
genomics can be used for diagnostics
the second thing when we also believe
is that genomics or whole genome
sequencing can help us
tailor um therapy
so instead of going from picking a
specimen and then doing various drug
sensitivity tests
for especially tb diagnosis and then
testing various drugs to come up with
which drugs we think that the patient
may respond to we want to get to a point
where
we can sequence the person's genome
and then align these sequences and
have some kind of algorithms ready that
will
link your sequence types
to the drugs that
one would need so basically
personalizing
therapy we also think that we can use
whole genome sequencing to track
outbreaks
so we're following an individual in the
population who is infected
we see how the next person is also
infected
and how it is spreading in the
population there are some changes
in the pathogen we can see that
there is a new variant in the pathogen
however at this stage we are just
tracking
the infection
so we can go further to use this to
manage the
outbreaks see whether the activities are
directed at the right persons and at the
right locations
but as you can see this man here is
asking
is that all no it's not finished we've
forgotten about
within host genetic diversity
so this is where we start looking at
how a pathogen in an individual
is changing or branching into
the b type or the c type and basically
this is where
the statisticians will bring their
statistics
on board and then we can eventually
develop
a nice phylogenetic tree to look at
how these pathogens are related
and on a time scale
now furthermore we can also
merge a number of these phylogenetic
trees
based on social networks let's say
various and
groupings in a society and come up with
a more complex
analysis like this then we can also
marry the epidemiological data to get
a final construction of a network of how
the pathogen is interacting the
pathogens are interacting
within individuals and also with
transmission
in a population but it's all not done
we can there are also certain very minor
variants
within this um population that we can
further
mine further complex and
the kind of analysis that we can do yeah
you may think that is all no there's
still a lot more that we can do with um
whole genome sequencing or ngs
we can use it to understand the dynamics
of infections
so basically if you sequence and
assemble your genomes
now you build your phylogenetic tree you
can plot the prevalence of these
subclones
across space and time to understand how
and why the epidemic is happening so
for public health this is one interest
the next thing is all to to use these
sequencing
data to discover completely brand new
pathogens
so for instance if you do a metagenomics
analysis of a patient with an unknown
disease you can blast
the reeds against the database of known
organisms
and look at the set of rates that didn't
match to any known organism
and then try and sequence in the lab and
piece
various um
regions together and if it is what
calling
a completely known pathogen then you do
so
now for something like um size group 2
we are comparing this novel pathogen
with other genomes within the genus
coronavirus grouping
to identify which regions have changed
by comparative genomics with a known
coronavirus and we established the new
sas co
covet 19. now we can also
use sequencing data to understand the
drivers and evolution
of within hosts and population level
evolution of resistance to these
pathogens
next what else we can do is to
track the date and time of a viral
infection not only viral infections
from our phylogenetic tree we can
pinpoint
the actual time of origin
of a new variant in the population
we can also use um genomics data
to do this therapeutic monitoring of
drug resistance so
you sequence an individual or a patient
and then you scan this genome for
mutations
and determine which drugs would work for
the person
if probably the person is already on a
certain drug
regimen you can change it based on the
genotypes that the individual
has got we can also use
pathogen genomics to understand the
population structure
of these pathogens you see how various
certain
pathogens are clustered or grouped
and others are separated so we see this
substructuring within the population to
understand
where which areas or for instance
which countries have similar pathogens
and basically how the pathogens are
structured in the various populations
that we are interested in
now for drug resistance we can also use
pathogen genomics to predict resistance
there are many mutations in the genome
some
may be compensatory but some may also
lead to resistance so you can look at it
which of the reverends will predict a
resistant phenotype
we can also use it for diagnosis um
[Music]
people are actually developing new
diagnostic tools
in um based on the sequences
that we generate from
pathogens and then in epidemiology
we use it to infer transmission of
genomics data it's not enough to
just sequence your genome
you need to marry it with the epi
information
of your population to understand
the transmission the dynamics of the
transmission
and how basically the pathogen
is driving this transmission
now i can't stop without talking about
malaria that is my area of interest so
i'll do a few slides on malaria
before i hand it over to ilia so for
malaria control
and elimination basically we are
targeting malaria elimination and
ultimate
eradication our goal is to come up with
new tools that will be useful for
diagnosis
for prevention and treatment and for
stopping transmission
or prevent reintroduction of parasites
in areas with zero prevalence so
as we are controlling the malaria
parasites
and the vectors and we get to
elimination what we are expecting is
very very low transmission
and when we get to the zero prevalence
um
that would be eradication but as we go
on transmission
is reducing so imagine that we will need
very
innovative ways of diagnosing the
disease
in let's say one in um
200 or one in a thousand people just
getting
malaria how can you pick such a low
infection
in a few people and how effectively we
can prevent and treat the disease
and also if there is a reintroduction
of the parasite in a population where
this parasite has already been
eliminated we can quickly
localize this infection and then deal
with it
now what do we have in our tool set at
the moment
we have a number of vector control
interventions such as
indoor residual spraying with
insecticides
and then long-lasting bed nets
to prevent fitted bed nets to prevent
transmission and then we have preventive
therapies
such as um sp sulfadoxin perimeter men
for pregnant women
for children and then intermittent
treatment of populations
with low transmission and then we have
our diagnostic kits microscopy
um rapid diagnostic testing and we have
our current atomicine-based combination
therapy for treatment
and we've established quite a strong
malaria surveillance system
and we have one vaccine that is at the
pilot implementation stage so
it's going through it's the phase four
pilot implementation it's been approved
and currently being tested in um
ghana kenya and um malawi
yeah they're thinking about how it can
be ruled out
successfully you know our
countries so these are what we have in
our two sets
but the challenge is the extensive
genetic diversity in the parasite genome
so you see how diverse the parasite can
look like
and for the malaria parasite there are
many levels
from the mosquito stage it
adapts it adapts in the mosquito through
diversity and then it moves into the
liver stage of the individual
and there again it diversifies
its genome in order to be able to evade
the liver stage and then moves into the
paras the red blood
cell and again it has to undergo
extensive diversity
so this makes it very complex for any
malaria
and genomic studies or malaria
intervention
the idea of the parasites extensive
diversity
is just to evade the host immune system
and
pressures such as the drug and the
vaccines that
we take and unfortunately for us
the current anti-malaria therapy the
atomism-based combination therapy
is already showing signs of resistance
the parasite is resisting this and
drag and we see this in the greater
mekong
region around cambodia thailand and the
rest
and recently in africa in rwanda
resistance to the acts has also emerged
and we already have insecticide
resistance
also in the vectors the mosquitoes
and there is a deletion in the genes
that are
used in developing a rapid diagnostic
test so what are we left with
yeah so the but the good news is that
with all the advancement in technology
for malaria elimination we have a number
of tools
we are evolving from doing simple
um nucleotide or nucleic acid
amplification techniques like
pcr for genotyping molecular bar coding
we are advancing to microarray
technology
whole genome sequencing we also have
whole transcriptome
sequences and then that gene drive
using techniques like the crispr cast
gene editing then we also have
a huge genetic or genomics database
or repository that we can tap from
some of these resources i have listed
here we have the human genome
so we can look at the human genome the
parasite genome
the mosquito genome is also available we
have plasmodb
gin db the malaria gen
pf 3k genome we have the
mosquito thousand genome
ncbi genbank and vector base
these are some of the tools that have
stored a huge database
um yes you may not find enough
metadata to go with it but there is a
lot that we can explore
together with our own sequences that we
have generated
and some of the questions that we can
ask
by using whole genome sequencing or
any genotyping platform
is to understand or get some insight
into the
the parasites biology its ability to
adapt
and track these parasites as they
respond to
interventions like the drugs or vaccines
or even now
the
parasites genomic data is being used
as proxy for vector control
interventions um to understand
transmission
the reason being that as the
vectors are being shrunk by the
interventions like the indoor residual
spraying
or the
bed nets they shrink with a parasite
population and so these parasites
remaining after these interventions have
become proxy for
estimating transmission after vector
control interventions
we can also look at genetic mapping by
linkage or
genome-wide association studies
genome-wide association studies have
been used to look at
regions of the genome that are under
strong
recent selection and these have been
seen
for candidates for um
drug-resistant candidates new graduates
and candidates have been
developed or detected using genome-wide
scans for these signatures of grace and
selection
and then they can also be manipulated to
look for
causal variants so if you are interested
in phenotypes like
severe malaria are there any causal
variants to
severe malaria we can also map
the genome or transcriptome
to look at differential expression
patterns
throughout the various life cycles of
the stages of the life cycle to enable
us identify
new drug and vaccine targets and this is
an
area that not much has been
done we also need preemptive
surveillance of the african parasite
population for genetic markers
of emergence of drug resistance because
um
apart from just tracking
the genotypes that have been like the
genes or variants or mutations that have
been
associated with or have been identified
as functional for
sct resistance there are
signs that we may have different
mutations apart from what has been
established
in the greater mekong region so it's
important to look for
what is lincoln
drug resistance in the greater mekong
region i'm talking about the k-13 gene
here
there are new variants in the k-13 that
may
explain or give us a different pattern
for our resistance
and of course we know that the k-13 gene
alone is not the gene responsible
may not be the only gene responsible for
atomic resistance so
there is a need to look for other
markers of um
drug resistance and then we need new
tools to develop
drugs vaccines insecticides and
diagnostic tools as i mentioned
there are deletions in the
genes used for the um rapid diagnostic
tech
and these will require some insulin co
designs
but we also have to think about
validating whatever
signals we pick from the genomes or
transcriptome
or proteome with laboratory validations
so the long story
is summarized here i'm saying that you
should take home
the fact that if you have a clinical
diagnosis of an infectious disease
you can look at the epidemiology or
laboratory procedures that is what we do
we do um disease population surveillance
disease outbreak investigations we take
samples and isolate
dna and we do traditional and
identification
look for drug resistance but we can
go further by using sequencing and
bioinformatic tools to
get more insight in the sequences that
we generate
so we do our pcr amplification we
assemble our sequence and then
we do our pathogen identification
you map it onto reference genomes you do
your comparative
genomics and phylogenetic analysis
clinical genotyping
but with this huge database
huge sequence database we will get more
insights that will lead to
discovery of new drug targets
new vaccines understand the biology
behind
our pathogens and
more insights into the emergence
of resistance or how resistance
the mechanism underlining resistance and
a huge area of
immune responses that i'm not even
touching and ultimately this will inform
public health
for disease control and prevention
and then clinical medicine for our
well-being
so i thank you for your time and i'll
hand over to
ilia to continue with the presentations
thank you
thank you anita if you could hold for
just one second there's a few
questions that people want to know so
abraham paul is asking thank you for
this presentation dr anita please
what is your group doing to improve the
malaria diagnosis
are you working on alternative diagnosis
maybe cheaper
rapid or more sensitive techniques for
malaria what is your malaria diagnostic
focus
in your group thank you thank you very
much
abraham well i personally am not
currently working on diagnostic tools
but
at noguchi dr linda amwa
she experienced the
[Music]
national malaria control programs and
surveillance of this um hrp
two and three deletions
in ghana and i know that
ultimately she'll come up with new
diagnostic
tools she's also exploring the genome so
that group is handling diagnosis but
definitely
there is some work in exploring the
genome having seen that the hrp2 gene
or three gene there are some deletions
and therefore we are not
picking them and they are not properly
diagnosed in malaria
and another question is what is the
status of plasmodium population
structure
in ghana from francis
so the plasmodium population is
extensively diverse in
ghana um we don't
have a complete ghana plus medium
population structure data but we have
looked at population structure in
various
regions in the country and
we have three major ecological zones so
for the middle builds for the coastal
belt and then the northern belt
we have looked at the population
structure
yes in the northern zone
there are a few clusters but
ultimately it is
very very heterogeneous
so we think that the interventions
are slowly breaking down the
structure and there's a lot of gene flow
across
all the sites in ghana
this is explaining a very extensive
diversity and heterogeneous population
structure we see
thank you and the last question i
believe what is the pattern between
villages and cities and and
i will just mention for the rest of the
questions
uh we will continue to speak about
malaria so
um after this last question from francis
we'll come back to questions
in a few slides after this
so what is the pattern
from village to cities well
so these are the things that we have to
track unfortunately we are
not really tracking but um
we expect a pattern
because of a lot of migration we expect
to see a pattern
and again as i said the parasite
population is very very
diverse unless we get a specific
marker that we can use to track this
particular pattern
um we know that people are moving
migration is very
rife in ghana but the population is so
diverse and
even though we have not specifically
looked at
patterns from village to cities
yeah okay thank you very much dr ganza
and we'll come back to these uh
important and interesting questions in
just a few more minutes so um thank you
again for
sharing this important information i
think it was very fascinating to hear
all of this
and i want to kind of turn your
attention now to some
more practical overview of this upcoming
training that will start with a focus on
how
bioinformatics can be leveraged for
infectious disease research
and specifically in the context of
today's webinar how can bioinformatics
help us
analyze host vector pathogen interaction
so before i continue i want to kind of
connect some of the things that were set
up until now
so when we joined the first part was an
introduction to omixlogic which is a
program
that is designed to facilitate
bioinformatics training and we also
heard about dr anita gansa
about how bioinformatics could be
applied in so many different ways
and i think what's important for anyone
who is
starting to utilize bioinformatics is to
have
a complete roadmap for bioinformatics
and so what i will try to do in my
portion of this presentation
is to help connect some of these
important and significant topics in
infectious disease research
with specific practical uh hands-on
tools that anyone can use and i want to
try and
make it as broad as possible to involve
people that maybe have
zero background in bioinformatics as
well as people that might already
have some experience in bioinformatics
but would like to
enrich their skills and make the most
out of
this upcoming opportunity for training
so
a complete road for bioinformatics in my
opinion
has to do with finding data sets that
might be able to be used for
answering the types of questions that
we've discussed
some practical skills on exploring and
visualizing these data sets to guide our
hypothesis
development to understand research
methods that are being used
in cutting-edge research publications so
that we can implement
similar methods to analysis of our own
or similar data sets
and gaining insights and understanding
that are validated and we are confident
in
so really that is the objective and in
today's
webinar what we wanted to talk about is
a little bit
how bioinformatics could be leveraged in
very practical ways
and then to talk about some examples
that we will cover
in the upcoming program for those that
might be interested in some of these
aspects
so as you know the major difference
between infectious diseases
and non-infectious diseases is that
infectious diseases in general
are caused by pathogens and they spread
and so they're also called
communicable diseases but as anita
already
pointed out there are so many factors
involved
and one of the primary factors beyond
the study of the pathogen itself
is how does that pathogen cause disease
or what
is the process of pathogenesis how do
these pathogens replicate
how do they cause different toxins
to be released and harm the host
and ultimately how can we study the
impacts of this disease progression at
different stages
and caused by different pathogens
another important part of that
is obviously how can the immune system
be leveraged to stop prevent
and protect people from these kinds of
pathogens
and so in the context of vaccine design
what dr anita already mentioned
we have a number of important
interventions that have been designed
maybe over a hundred years ago already
that have shown to reduce
the rates of infection and protect the
larger
uh portion of the population from such
infections and these are not
just the vaccines in fact some of the
most basic things like
uh use of chlorine in water
or for example separation
from different types of species have
caused an immense reduction
in the rates of infection and then the
vaccines
have also revolutionized the way that
people have dealt with
infections over the past decade or over
the past
uh sorry 100 years and so today
when we're looking at how we arrived at
a place
when we are again dealing with a
pandemic
that is surpassing the rates of death
from other non-communicable diseases is
something that requires us to rethink
this strategy of prevention and
antiviral
intervention or anti-pathogen
intervention measures
so when we think today where we are
in our ability to understand how
pathogens
overcome the traditional methods how
new pathogens are causing important
dangerous outbreaks like we see in covet
19
and how we all know that covet 19 is
just
one of coronaviruses that have been
around and have been causing
mild mild disease in the past
so how can similar changes in pathogens
can ultimately cause another outbreak
and how can we be prevent
prepared for that and my proposal here
is to say that
as researchers all of us play a major
role
in that preparedness and a lot of what
dr agansa already mentioned including
the understanding of the basic
mechanisms of replication transmission
and pathogenesis our understanding of
how
the virus causes disease in the host
response
and our ability to leverage such data
in a rapid way to quickly identify
insights that could be practically
translated
to active measures we are talking about
essentially putting all of this data in
context
so what's really amazing is the speed
at which such data has been gaining
uh or accelerating over the past
maybe decade or two in fact
today we live in an era of exponential
growth
of uh structural data genomic data
transcriptomic data all kinds of high
throughput data
that ultimately together indicate how
hosts interact with pathogens and how we
can leverage the immune responses and
the natural defenses of different
organisms
to really understand disease and be much
more informed about the opportunities to
be effective at
intervention and so what we want to do
in this training program that we're
going to describe
in just a few more minutes about how
this program is going to be organized
delivered
and how all of you can register we would
like to
focus on a few different types of
infectious disease
data sets and that includes viral
genomics and
evolution immune response and biomarkers
and the microbiome and infection
and in fact if you look at this kind of
data you will see
that a lot of such data really
contextualizes
what we already know so we see that from
the time that the human genome has been
sequenced
now there has been a parallel growth in
our understanding of the human genome
as well as in the genomes of different
viruses
that have been studied in the context of
the microbiome
and in the context of what's called the
virum which is
probably even more complex than the
metagenome
and so when we look at the changes in
the way that sequencing data is
generated
when we look at the ways that different
types of data
can categorize different forms of life
or even how we can study different forms
of infection that are caused by maybe
non-living things like
viruses and try to place them in the
categories that we have to deal with
in the tree of life so the key
technology to all of these
as was already mentioned is next
generation sequencing
and one important part to start
leveraging
next generation sequencing effectively
is
a workflow to help transform next
generation sequencing
into structured data that could be
readily analyzed
by anyone and so one of the things that
we would like to introduce you today
is a platform that can help you
gain the most out of available data sets
that you might have generated in the lab
or that are publicly available so that
you can
generate hypotheses from publicly
available data sets
or be more effective at extracting
greater
insights and more detailed and precise
insights
from the data that you generate so
what's out there
in terms of publicly available next
generation sequencing data so
first of all we can see that in the past
two decades there has been an
exponential growth
of genomic data about pathogens
in different public repositories and
that
includes different types of repositories
like the ncbi and so you've probably
heard of the recent
kind of update to ncbi virus where there
are over 13
000 genomes and if we're talking about
malaria or other kinds of non-viral
diseases
not ncbi virus but ncbi itself has also
huge collections of these genomes but
they're also specialized repositories
for
specific diseases not only that today
as we all know we hear about genomic
data
all the time and so even the greater
population not researchers and not
students of these topics are now
familiar
with the relevance of identification of
specific variants the impact of variance
on transmission and pathogenesis
and how critical this data is to
our ability to understand and track
these infectious diseases
now beyond that we also have the host
data so for example
on the gene expression omnibus on the
ncbi repository that is dedicated to
gene expression studies
there are over 80 000 publicly available
data sets
that speak about drug response that show
us how pathogenesis happens and allow us
to interrogate
how different types of genomic
variations from the host
can have a difference on the way that
disease is manifested in different hosts
and how it is carried by different
vectors and
more importantly there are novel
techniques that are emerging
like metagenomic and viral sequences or
even real-time sequences of
outbreaks that allow us to understand
the disease
and contextualize it with what's
happening
around that for example how that relates
to the different
measures that the health ministry can
implement and how that has to do with
different types of interventions so i
think that we're really
living in an era of big data
that is defined by the different types
of data
that is defined by also different types
of applications of data so it's
extremely significant
that we all have the ability and the
tools
to effectively manage analyze and
interpret such data
efficiently and so one important thing
about this is that
not only has the data become more and
more affordable
as a result of the diversification of
the different types of data generation
we can see also a variety of different
formats
and so before i continue our interest in
this webinar is to present you with the
upcoming program
and tell you some of the topics that we
will cover but it is also
to get to know you and so before i
continue
i obviously do not know many of you or
the majority of you
and so i would like to propose a few
questions so that we can
ask and get the information about the
current participants
so the first question that i have is
what is your current level of education
so if you could please look at these
questions and put the response
by putting for example 1b for
undergraduate degree
or 1d for postgraduate so the first
question
is what is your current level of
education 1a
high school or no degree 1b
undergraduate degree or
bachelor's 1c graduate degree or
master's
and d postgraduate phd and that also
is for those that are
researchers and faculty
okay thank you very much and by the way
we will use this information
uh to further tailor our uh webinars
and sessions uh in the future to provide
you with more
um information relevant to you okay
excellent thank you so i see a lot of
one b's
and one d's all right and one c is also
some i see you okay
great excellent thank you very much and
my second question is
you know this webinar is introducing you
to an
upcoming training program that is hosted
by the naguchi memorial
institute for biomedical research and so
we are interested to know how the
information that you've seen
so far could be interesting for you
so the questions for the second question
is what do you or what yes what do you
expect from this program
2a learn about bioinformatics 2b get
familiarized with infectious diseases
2c overview of bioinformatics and
biology
2d apply bioinformatics to a research
project so what
would you say characterizes your
personal interest the most
okay excellent so a lot of 2ds which is
applying bioinformatics
to a research project and i assume that
is because most of you are already
studying
infectious diseases and hopefully out of
this session you would get a little bit
more information of
how bioinformatics could be applied to
your research
and also what are the specifics not just
broad topics like we've discussed up
until now
but what are the specific practical
skills that you can gain from here
okay so i have another two questions so
thank you again for
all of your answers here number one what
is your primary
interest in terms of your research
because many of you answered that you're
interested in research
so 3a parasites like malaria for example
3b
viral infection like coven 3c bacterial
infection like tuberculosis
3d all of the above or any infectious
disease so you're really disease
agnostic
okay so here are some so please yes make
sure you answer with the right um three
okay 3d 3c okay so a lot of
a variety of different interests thank
you
um and uh the last question for today's
session
is um again what is your primary
interest
in terms of what are you interested to
apply bioinformatics to
and sorry this should be for 4a
pathogen 4b host response
4c vector transmission and 4d host
pathogen vector interaction
okay i'll just give here a minute for
anyone
to finish answering these questions
all right excellent thank you very much
for your answers
we are going to analyze your answers to
really inform
our next series of webinars and uh
the training sessions that we will have
in the program
let me briefly introduce you to some
resources
that we will leverage throughout this
program
so as anita already or sorry as beeps
already mentioned in the very beginning
of this webinar
we have a training portal that all of
you are invited to register in
and all of you are invited to start
exploring
even creating a free account because in
the context of this upcoming training
program
we will leverage a variety of resources
related
to this portal so here once you have
registered
you will see a variety of courses that
are designed around specific
types of omics data that go from
the very basics all the way to the more
advanced
bioinformatics methodology and all of
these resources
could be used asynchronously to study on
your own
however for many people having
asynchronous resources like coursera edx
or the tbi
info platform is not really enough and
so what we will try to do
in this program is guide the
participants
from where you currently are with or
without any bioinformatics background
to understand the specific details
of bioinformatics so that you can be
independent
in your research to ask questions of
data
and get results or answers to your
questions
so in the context of this program this
is one important resource that you will
have access to and you can start looking
over
the courses here or some of the
collections of courses
and projects that you will find that
take
a specific data set and explain
what that data set could be used in the
context
of a research question now let's talk
about
some specifics so specifically when we
talk about bioinformatics
the journey of a bioinformatician starts
with finding a data set and so when we
speak about
genomic data there are major two types
of data that provide this
with genomic information about the
pathogen
we can look at fast q files that provide
us
with an in-depth look of what's in our
sequencing data
or we can deal with faster files that
can describe
genomic variation that could later on be
interpreted
so one of the applications of these is
to
understand the significance of mutations
in terms of codon mapping
and the impact of a particular mutation
on
the amino acid and even on the structure
of a protein
as you probably are all familiar
familiar with
this could be done by leveraging
multiple sequence alignment
at the nucleotide or amino acid level
and understand the relationship between
sequences
using what's called phylogenetic tree
reconstruction
so one of the important parts of what we
will go through
in this program is take these different
examples that we just looked at
ebola virus tuberculosis malaria and
analyze those genomic sequences both as
consensus sequences in faster files but
also
in raw next generation sequencing data
so that we can
look at the in-depth mutation analysis
that reveal haplotypes and different
populations
of host pathogens and how they interact
so for example
one of the things that we will do is we
will look at geospatial analysis where
we can link specific sequences
to their location and the time where
they have been found
another important use for such data
is to find single nucleotide
polymorphisms
and in the context of big data
it is a challenge because we will look
at the
impact of coverage on our ability to
detect
low frequency mutations and
differentiate between
low and high frequency mutations to
study populations of pathogens
but also the emergence of dominant
strains
and how we can characterize those in
large
groups of samples for example when we
talk about cobit 19
when the first sequence was put together
was assembled
that looked like this you have a lot of
different reads
those reads have been mapped on some
reference and a consensus sequence
has been provided but when we talk about
analysis of such data there are many
indicators
that we can extract from such data that
will allow us to ask
very different questions about how this
consensus sequence
could be compared to other consensus
sequences or how can the raw fascu data
can reveal
different types of snips different types
of combinations of snips
and different types of information about
their relationships
now in the context of such practical
analysis
we will use our t-band for platform
for big data so let me show you what
that looks like
so again this is the educational portal
edu dot
t dash bio dot info now we can go
to server dot t dash bio
dot info so server t bio
info and so uh beeps if you could please
post the
link and also a demo account and so i
want to introduce this platform
in the context of an efficient tool
that you can leverage in your omics data
research
so here we will talk about how you can
take fast q files or fasta files
and by the way thank you beeps for
posting the link and the username and
password anyone can
log in with this username and password
just to kind of explore some demo
examples of what we will go through and
here
anyone even without knowledge of
bioinformatics
and without access to high throughput
computing resources with large ram
and large storage can analyze publicly
available data sets as well as private
data sets that you have generated in
your lab
so here you'll find many different
sections for next generation sequencing
data analysis
for mass spec structural biology
as well as data integration and modeling
and especially
a section that was designed around
virology studies
so here you can see a number of
different examples
for example how you can build a
phylogenetic tree
and this could be done using fast q
files
or assemble genomes in fasta files
we will also look at how to analyze
transcriptomic data so for example how
we can build
a whole pipeline to study
patterns in our next generation
sequencing data
for transcriptomic data analysis and
this is a really
simple tool that will
eliminate the complexity of
bioinformatics analysis
to produce interesting results that you
can gain
insights from without any coding
and without having to have your own
high throughput computing resources so
here for example we are looking at
an example of mapping a sample
to a reference genome to find alignment
of reads to the reference genome and
even look
at how we can find variants in the
sequence
or understand what those reads represent
so these kinds of examples in the
context of
again viral infection bacterial
infection
and parasite infection we will look at
these kinds of studies
as well as the host response so
what are the different sections that we
will cover we'll cover
phylogenetic analysis gene expression
analysis
alignment with multiple sequence
alignment or alignment of reads to
reveal snips
variant calling and even structural
biology how we can map those variants
onto structures of proteins understand
the impact
of mutations on the function of
a particular protein so as i mentioned
this platform will help you build the
logic of analysis
combining multiple scripts into what's
called bioinformatics pipelines
understand the different inputs and
outputs in terms of the logic or the
sequence of how they are connected
together
understanding each method that are
explained
as you build your pipeline different
types of
inputs and outputs for analysis
including
this example of transcriptomic data
analysis
you will see how such a guided process
with the help of our trainers will help
you establish
a logic behind these workflows and make
reproducible research and importantly
you will find access to a variety of
different sections
that are all built around a similar
interface
so using this platform and a number of
other resources we will talk about
sequence variation evolutionary
relationships
relationships between function and
structure
and host response either as a vector
or as an host and so that way you can
start contextualizing
some of these questions that we
discussed in this webinar
in the context of available data sets
that we will also introduce you to
and in the context of how to transform
your questions
into a specific um
transcript in a specific uh analysis
approach so to conclude
i wanted to open up now a
question uh slime
so if you had any questions uh about
this
program uh you can post that here
you can also post questions about some
of the topics that we discussed related
to analysis
and to help guide us in this discussion
i also have here a number of questions
that you can
think about so that we can have an
effective discussion so
the first one is which university or
department you are currently
in then how often do you deal with next
generation sequencing data in your lab
or in your research or in your studies
and typically is it generated by you or
have you
or do you currently leverage publicly
available data sets or maybe both
three what is your current training
experience with bioinformatics
sorry this should be three and this
should be four
and how needed is additional training in
bioinformatics for you
or for your department so these are some
questions
uh to help guide this discussion um you
can
definitely put your answers into the
chat box
and if you are interested in kind of
unmuting yourself and asking the
question or
answering one of these questions
publicly please feel free to do that as
well
okay so i see that rhodes university
some james is answering that he's an
intern at the naguchi immunology
department
um manav rajna dental college okay and
i'm assuming that the majority here
are from the uh naguchi um
uni okay so
i'm not so familiar with the
abbreviations like k-n-u-s-t
and k-c-c-r
all right thank you humboldt university
phd student
university of health and allied sciences
excellent thank you very much so we hope
that these
free sessions like today will be of
interest and beneficial to you to not
only learn about bioinformatics but also
gain some practical exposure to
bioinformatics methods of analysis
we have included a variety of different
free resources that most of you will
have
access to but also in just a few moments
many of you will be introduced to our
upcoming
training program which is a paid program
and some of those paid programs will
also include some free webinars
so we'll go over that schedule in just a
few minutes
so as you stay you'll see
more information on that
okay sweden ghana medical center
biochemical engineering indian institute
of technology bhu undergraduate and
junior
okay thank you um victor is saying has
not yet gained
access to next generation sequencing
data
all right thank you very much suez canal
university egypt okay thank you dr manna
abboyle care
okay thank you phd student biotechnology
from
ben gurion university in israel all
right great to see you here abraham
nmimr university of ghana thank you dido
okay um lewis is saying that he's aware
of the data sets available and hope to
use them
and uh victor is saying that he has
basic experience on bioinformatics
beginner
university of the western cape south
africa all right
excellent so again thank you all for
your answers
we will just keep this for one more
minute so please answer some of your
questions
and again we will also be interacting
with you so as you're going
through um these questions uh
i also want to mention that one of the
first courses that we invite you to
complete
in the context of bioinformatics
training
is a free introduction to bioinformatics
asynchronous course
that is on the edu.t bioinfo website
and on this website you will find that
the first lesson
is actually a survey and so we're really
looking forward
to learning more about you about your
background
about your interests hoping that we can
leverage the resources that we already
have
to help you get more hands-on experience
okay so thank you again all of you for
the
answers i think that an
important part of what we have discussed
today
is not only the training and the lessons
and the education
but i think that in many cases we are
interested in taking this further and
applying bioinformatics tools
to a particular project and so to speak
about projects
what projects are and how such training
is going to help you develop
a project of your own i am going to
pass the presentation over to dr mohit
mizunder
who is our project coordinator
and a business development uh person
so mohit i'll pass it on to you
you ilya and thank you
to the other presenters anita and
deepisha
let me share my screen
okay hello everyone uh a very good
evening to all the participants
my name is mohit mazumdar and in my
current role i'm collaboratively working
with universities and research
institutes
and labs to provide support for
bioinformatics research and training
i'm really excited excited to be to be a
part of this omix logic and pictures
disease research program
as a project mentor and to be able to
work on translational research
with a diverse group of students faculty
with diverse expertise so my phd was
focused
on using bioinformatics and data science
techniques to predict and identify
biological patterns
and with this experience of working on
several published research projects
as a project mentor i will i will help
the program participants
with analysis steps and understanding
the sequence data and the pattern within
and further use structural biology tools
and computational modeling of biological
systems
to develop a deeper understanding of the
system biology
so as you know and as we have been
discussing so far
bioinformatics and application of ngs
and clinical data
are increasingly contributing in both
academia
and pharmaceutical industry research and
development
and this is quite evident from the rapid
data growth generation that is happening
right now so our understanding of
infectious disease
caused by bacterial pathogens such as
mycobacterium tuberculosis
and parasites such as plasmodium
falciparum
as well as viruses such as ebola and
kovid 19.
so today i will introduce you to
several uh examples of how this
example of how this can be done
successfully by researchers
um who are studying viral infections
such as ebola
virus outbreak in west africa covid 19
pandemic as well as
microbial pathogen uh that we discussed
tuberculosis
and the single cell parasites which is
malaria
so we will briefly touch on viral
genomics and
evolution gene expression patterns
transcriptomics that was discussed
detection of
significant genomic variants as well as
look into the microbiome and the viral
communities in a host
that will help us to you know find those
important associations
with disease susceptibility and those
outcomes
so this uh kind of investigation is
going to be really fascinating because
we will be kind of uh focused on as
and this has been discussed about the
disease outbreaks and
pathogenesis host pathogen uh genomic
variations
and then host immune invasion mechanisms
so these are really exciting and you
know
very important topics that we will be
talking about including the
identification of biomarkers
or vaccine targets so in the context
of this training program many of the
projects
we have been developing and will be used
as an example
so mutation mutation profiling of ebola
virus outbreak
as i mentioned and then origin of and
pathogenesis of noble coronavirus
as well as noble techniques on low
frequency mutation studies in including
cersei sequencing in polio virus
so as you see that we have uh
we will be using amino acid and three
dimensional structure and
ngs data to be able to understand the
research question that has been posed
so this research
that we will be doing and that we have
been discussing and we will be
discussing
uh in the next few slides will include
scheduled and structured training
and the purpose of this doing this is to
leave this training should lead to a
research
outcome so in this program we will
combine online sessions
guided study material um so we will have
online sessions like the one that we are
having right now
and then we have uh these courses and
hands-on guide
and tutorials so we will use those
and then we will be using practical
assignments for this immersive
experience that has been proven
effective in our well-respected
omics logic programs so in order to make
the most of this training
we will be helping and guiding you
throughout this training
so with this uh let me invite our omics
logic trainer dr harpreet cart
so dr harpreet score is one of the
trainers that will help
facilitate many of the sessions and her
areas of specialization
is in ngs data genomics transcriptomics
and application of machine learning so
with this i will give it to over to you
dr
dr core thank you dr mohit
let me share my screen
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics
uh during my uh doctor research my focus
is on biomarker discovery
for the diagnosis and the prognosis of
the liver cancer
so what inspired me to take liver cancer
as my doctoral research topic is the
high mortality rate of this malignancy
and lack of the precise my biomarker
that that helped to diagnose liver
cancer
at an early stage so liver cancer
is considered as sixth major cancer in
terms of
incidence and fourth in terms of
mortality
so then what are the uh major issues
that are associated with the liver
cancer include
is inaccurate diagnosis and then it's
late diagnosis specifically in the
latest days
and then another reason that results for
the poor prognosis of the patients
is the tumor reoccurrence so keeping
these concern in mind
we have uh try to address
uh these issues using various
bioinformatics approaches
so in the first part we have extracted
the
nearly 4000 sample from the public
repository that are associated with the
hepatocellular carcinoma
and by employing different
bioinformatics techniques
we have identified three gene based
biomarker
that can include clec1b fcn3 and prc1
in the next part we focused on the
second uh
primary malignancy of the liver cancer
that is chlangiocarcinoma
for this purpose we have retrieved
nearly
900 samples from the one of major public
repository that is geo
and then we have lucidated uh three
ccs pacific signature which include lam
c2 itc and c2
uh employing various machine learning
techniques like random forest logistic
regression
svm etc and in next part to
identify liver cancer at an early stage
we have
explored transcriptomics as well as the
methylation data
of the three nearly 350 scc patients
and then employing various statistical
and bioinformatics techniques that
include random forest than various
feature selection technique
eventually we have identified 51
signature that
include 30 rna transcript and 21
methylation cpg sites
that can predict liver cancer at an
early stage
so keeping overall inconclusion from
this my
doctor research eventually we have
identified three gene based biomarker to
predict
scc and then to predict cca
and then we have identify 51 signature
to predict liver cancer at an early
stage
so in my current role
i am omixlogic bioinformatics trainer
so with continuation to my research here
we are designing
different research projects
based on the public data sets so for
example in the first project
is already dr mohit has
shown you that is based on the uh
reason and the pathogenesis of noble
coronavirus that is
sar scope 2 so in this process
we will explore explore the ngs data
to understand its origin and how much it
related with already existing
human coronavirus strains and
here in this project further we will try
to understand
what are important components of the
viruses through which they
enter into the human cell subsequently
we also look into how it is different
from
other coronavare strains in terms of
mutations
so in the later part of this project we
also try to identify
important signature that can
significantly different
under different therapeutic treatment
and untreated conditions
besides we have also developed a project
on another pandemic that is evola
so in this project we used next
generation sequencing data
to monitor the pandemic here we employed
various bioinformatics approaches to
analyze genomic sequences identify
particular viruses in the patient sample
through the identification of
significant
variance determine the relationship
between viruses
and identify shared origin of viral
genomes
and eventually we will try to try to
understand
to identify a connection between genomic
variation
and this is phenotypes
so during this upcoming program
uh many of you can explore these
projects
that are specifically based on the
infectious disease
and i'm looking forward to become your
project mentor
uh during this program now i would like
to invite pizza
to talk about registration process
so over to you vipsa sir thank you so
much dr harpreet
i'll be quickly sharing my screen over
here
and let me take you through the next
steps
as we know that a lot of you have
questions about how to register
for the program what is the schedule so
we will be going over them very quickly
in this upcoming three-month training
program
we will discuss in depth about
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
go over an in-depth training in genomics
transcriptomics as well as have
do a research project that already dr
mohit
and dr harpreet has been showing
we have designed this program to
introduce
the data resources and tools that you
can use to apply
binder matrix to publicly available data
on
infectious diseases in this program we
will
understand viral diversity and its role
in
epidemic infectious diseases that keep
re-emerging
including zoonotic transmission
transmission between
humans and the process of viral
and bacterial disease development we'll
learn about bioinformatics
analysis approaches to study viral
genome
and understand the relationships between
viral strains haplotypes
find differences in sequence data and
see the implications
for drug and vaccine design you will
gain
hands-on experience by analyzing curated
data sets from public domain collections
guided by experts with bioinformatic
experience
and knowledge about biology
here is an example of a pro project
that dr gansha was
part of along with her collaborator
dr emeka where they used transcriptomic
analysis of sarskoff to
so this project again is available uh
on our youtube channel and i will be
sharing the link
with everyone after this program if
you're already registered for the
program and have registered for this
webinar you will receive an email with
the details
to all of these projects and learn more
about how this entire process works out
now moving on uh so if you are
already a member of uh noguchi
memorial then you have to reach out to
dr
anita and you will also receive an email
for us regarding the rest of the
registration process for those of you
who are not part of nogochi and are
still
interested in attending this three-month
program
so this is not a one-month program this
is a three month program
and we will be dealing with all of these
topics in greater details
and here you can see the breakdown of
the different pricing
uh on our screen so i will just keep it
on for a few more minutes
and there are also scholarships
available
for participants who are not able to
afford the program prices
so if a participant indicates a high
level
of motivation and also provides us with
a rationally to seriously consider
this request our team will reach out to
you
and you will have to note down your
references
and together we will reach out to you
talk to your references and see
whether you are fit for the scholarship
program
and then upon approval you will receive
scholarship to the program
and the scholarships we offer are
designed to
help motivated talented and promising
students to benefit from
special training and research
opportunities the criteria for approval
includes a reasonable need
indication of extra effort that the
participant
is willing to put into the program and
time commitment
needed to go beyond the regular training
so
to be able uh to get
access to the whole program a
participant who
is under a scholarship would need to
keep a record of the topics covered in
each of the sessions
in what we call a virtual lab journal
and you would be required to give us a
review of each of the sessions that you
are going through
make that extra effort so that we know
that you are taking this seriously
and we will also be sharing with you uh
what this scholarship
looks like and
now this is the first course
that i had uh spoken about earlier elia
had also mentioned which is the
introduction to bioinformatics
so if you have not yet taken this course
you can go to edu.t health and
buyer.info and under courses you will
find this free course
and this free course also comes with a
certificate
so you can get started with it right
away if you have not yet done any of the
courses
and you can see that there are a lot of
reviews by
other participants have taken this
course
before you
and all of the activity that you do in
the course of this program
is being tracked to help you understand
your progress
and evaluate your effort at the end of
the program
uh to issue and for you to get a
certificate and for us to issue that
certificate to you
we found that the most successful
participants are able to learn new
methods
develop an independent project in the
course of
these almonds logic program now let me
take you
to the website and show you how the
registration process
works so that it is clear uh
for all of you okay nine i'm going to be
posting the link
direct link to introduction to
bioinfomatrix right now
in the chat box so for this program
many of you have already signed up and
we have your details so we will reach
out to you regarding the next step so
please
look out for emails from marketing at
pine dot bio
where i would be sharing with you
details about the program
any free resources details about
upcoming
free sessions as well so some of these
details
may be useful to you there would be
emails which may not be
useful for you because they may relate
to any other topic that you may not be
interested in so we keep on sharing all
of these resources
from time to time so you can choose to
attend a session or not attend a session
so moving on how to register for the
program
if you have not yet registered for the
program and are interested in attending
this
three-month program please fill out the
form
at the bottom of this page so you
see there is a pre-registration form
right here
and once you fill out that
pre-registration form you will receive
details about the program
and especially if you are someone who is
again
not from noguchi then the next step that
you have to do
is go to this page this is the
infectious disease
uh checkout page so
i'm posting the link again here
sorry about this i'll just go back
okay i got the link so in this page
you will find that the program starts
with a hands-on workshop on january 29th
and it goes on till march 8th
where we will have a group project so
this is a program
which starts with very basic
understanding and
builds up with the help of asynchronous
courses
live sessions like we are doing today
where you can directly interact with a
mentor
ask your questions get them answered in
a session
have your doubts cleared as well as do
hands-on analysis
with the tbi for platform or any of our
other platforms as well as
other tools using other tools like r and
python
along with your mentor so this is all
going to be
part of this three month training
program
so please register yourself by getting
started here
you will have all of these different
options
the first step if you have not yet
registered again is to go and
pre-register yourself here
and then check out using any of these
links for those in need of a scholarship
we have another page where you can
actually
talk about your scholarship
okay i'll post the link again i'm sorry
about this
yeah so the scholarship link is now in
the chat box
so if you are in need of a scholarship
please fill out the form at the bottom
of this page
and please make sure that you will have
to upload your cv
and also mention mention your references
and we would like to have a meeting with
you
as well as your reference to understand
where you are coming from and your
actual need
to uh get this scholarship and attend
this program
so it may be a long drawn-out process so
if you want to get started please start
applying for the program right now
and once you are enrolled in the program
you will get
access to different resources like the
course that you see here
so once you do each of these courses
each
course carries a certificate on their
own
as well as there would be a program
certificate right
at the end of the program okay so if you
have any questions
again regarding the resources please
feel free to reach out to me marketing
at pine.bio
for any questions regarding access to
the program
resources uh courses projects anything
and i would be happy to answer all of
these questions for you
if you are in norwich you can reach out
to dr anita
and dr bright ado and they will be able
to help you with the next steps of the
program
and moving on once you finish the
courses you are doing the online
sessions during this
three month period you will also come
across a lot of these projects which
would be available to you
and some of which uh dr harpreet has
already shown you
like the kovit 19 project the ebola
project and you would be able to take
advantage of these projects and have
that hands-on experience on how to
work on your own project and complete an
own project as well as conceive your own
project and complete it like
dr anita was talking about the malaria
project as well as her project with
uh dr chukwuka so you would be able to
do an independent research project
in the next three months so we are
starting
on january 29th we do not have a lot of
days so if you are looking forward to
register
kindly go ahead and register for the
program and now we are open to taking in
questions
uh so if you have any question uh please
post them down in the chat box or if you
want to unmute yourself and ask any
question
uh we are ready to take in any questions
from your end
so please feel free to ask us your
questions
and you can also continue to forward us
your questions to marketing and pilot
bio
and i would like to again invite you to
take a look at
our social media pages so
please go ahead and join our groups
as well as our group in linkedin
and uh dr anita do you want to add
anything right now
for the participants before we conclude
today's session
um thank you biph um i think that the
participants as has been said if you are
interested you can register
but those are noguchi some
are being fully supported
and they know themselves and the others
would have to register and then
you can get more information from dr
bright they do
of the immunology department as well so
you can reach out to dr do
dr anita can i share your email as well
in the chat box
in case someone wants to reach out and
you can also
yes please yeah okay so i will also post
dr
uh gansha's link yeah yeah banshika you
can go ahead and ask questions
and for francis yes we do have an
intensive internship at pine bio for
three months
or six months period so francis if you
can
share your email id i can reach out to
you you can send it to me
in the chat box and still i would like
to
take everyone one more time and show
so here is how you can register
for the program which is the research
fellowship program which we have
and as part of the research fellowship
program what we do
is go through projects like you are
seeing right now and we have been taking
some examples
so if you go through this link again you
will see
uh the project examples
from our previous participants
who have been part of programs like this
so they come from
backgrounds like neuroscience they come
from backgrounds like
oncology biology and many more
so you will be able to see all of that
project example here
developed as part of this research
fellowship program
and pradhu mesh the recording uh so the
video is already live
in youtube and it does not get deleted
so technically the recording is
available
so as you see these are some of the
projects that were developed as part of
the program
and you can go through this link and
let us know if you're interested in
doing the research project
however the training itself the
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
itself is a long two month uh
program which comes with first training
and then
the opportunity for you to develop your
own project related to infectious
disease research
in case you're interested in researching
on any other topic which is not related
to infectious diseases
definitely you can go for the research
fellowship program
uh are there any questions that you
would like us to answer
thank you so much francis i will be
reaching out to you
thank you for sharing your email id
so if you do not have any more questions
i would like to
thank all of our speakers today for
sharing
their insights and for such an exciting
session and for all
to all our participants for attending
today's session for asking your
questions
and for being part of this so we hope to
see you in the upcoming program
and thank you again for attending today
um babe sir before we go is there
another free
webinar before the 29th
uh yes uh on january 25th i suppose
yeah okay right yes
sending out those details uh
uh via email to everyone so that if you
are already
you know already registered via this
link you will get all the details
and if you are not registered already to
just get program updates related to
bioinformatics for infectious disease
again
please go ahead and just register here
and we will be sending you all the
updates once we have your details
so thank you again thank you
um nine uh you can uh completely fill up
the
scholarship form and we will be reaching
out to you
so thank you again for any other
questions please reach out to
marketing at pine.bio and i would end
today's session thank you everyone
have a nice week ahead
you